How do I treat an infected, small wound from a bird? Well, you know, that's a tough question
answer because it depends on how deep the bird is, what level of bird it is. If you're trying
to, if you have an infected wound, there's topical, from a medical standpoint, there's obviously
topical antibiotics, tributyptivatic appointments and things. From a natural perspective,
a person could use honey. That could help heal a wound and kill infection. A person could use
topical hydrogen peroxide. There's different topical treatments that are, if, if the wound is
a closed wound, it's not open anymore. You could use cumpri, if it's a closed, if it's a closed
wound, you could use calendula. There's other different appointments that a person could use on
a wound. If it's a bird that needs to be treated, if it's a third degree bird or something like that,
you're going to end up going into the ER that you don't want to be putting that anything on it
until you get in there because they're going to scrape that off. But if you're, if that's not the
case, and it's a small bird, and it's just a rule that seems to be festering and open,
then you want to make sure that it doesn't get infected. So that's where
a topical antibiotic, a hydrogen peroxide rate, but honey can be helpful in those cases.